tonight on the new reality
we knew this was going to be a problem
the sheer speed of this race
developing a vaccine in roughly a year
is also proving to be its greatest
handicap
not enough attention has been paid to
prepare the public
for what's coming if you will receive
the vaccine
raise your hand for years dan rather was
a familiar and trusted face in millions
of american homes
what is your assessment of the state of
america right now
well we are deeply divided there's no
question however the united states of
america
is not despite rumors the contrary
falling apart
hello from washington d.c i'm donna
friesen the presidential election is
over
the turnout was historic but this
country remains deeply divided
politically
the bitter partisanship is expected to
linger
my conversation about that with veteran
journalist dan rather is just ahead
but first a story about what the whole
world is waiting for
a vaccine for the coronavirus eleven
candidates are in phase three of human
clinical trials
one or more of them could be deemed safe
and effective
soon within months if not weeks canada
has already signed agreements with the
manufacturers of seven
vaccine candidates so that if they're
approved canadians will get millions of
doses
a vaccine is what could save lives and
release us from all the public health
restrictions
but you might be surprised how many
canadians are hesitant about it
these aren't so-called anti-vaxxers
these are people who believe in modern
medicine
who have had all the childhood vaccines
to protect against other serious
diseases
but a vaccine against cobit 19 carolyn
jarvis found plenty of canadians
who aren't so sure if you will receive
the vaccine once it is ready
and approved for use in canada raise
your hand
[Music]
and if you're going to wait
and if you are a hard no raise your hand
we assembled nine canadians from across
the country to discuss the covid19
vaccine
and where they stood on taking it graham
reed worked in the aerospace industry
until two months ago i got laid off from
uh probably
like my dream job i think i would take
the vaccine right away because having
that
vaccine i think will definitely help not
only myself get back to what you would
call normal
but i think would help the world
overcome this disease
no no no teresa singh is a mother and
for 16 years
she was a nurse you're not against
mainstream medicine
100 not i am not against mainstream
medicine i love it i respect the
specialist the doctors are brilliant
they're geniuses we need our health care
system but i think there is other
approaches we can be using instead of
this
rush job vaccine to a virus from what i
understand
mutate karen methvin is immune
suppressed
if you got covered what do you think
would happen i would essentially
if i got coveted watch myself
deteriorate till the point i had
pneumonia
and started organ failure and
i would die in a rather grotesque way so
the vaccine for you is life and death
yeah and you're putting your hand up
saying i'm first in line
if i could be first in line i would yes
at 74
brit bright has already lived through a
pandemic and
an epidemic and i have reduced lung
function today as a result of it
so i'm very much in favor of
anaconda vaccines phase 3 trial sign me
up
but many others who've stood in line for
all the traditional vaccines in the past
are hesitant about this one talking
about getting a vaccine out in 2021 that
is
unparalleled in anything that's happened
before in vaccine history
so we just don't have a good track
record on the risk of the vaccine
the sheer speed of this race developing
a vaccine in roughly a year
when it usually takes five to ten is
also proving to be its greatest handicap
what people want is more time i'm not
gonna get it until i'm satisfied and i
think i'll be satisfied in about
two years there are usually mistakes
when you
typically rush things in general in a
new poll for global news conducted by
ipsos
54 of canadians agreed they'd take a
covet vaccine as soon as possible
but of those only 22 percent of
canadians felt strongly about it
and when we asked about concerns over
side effects more than 80 percent of
people said they'd wait
to see what happens there was this naive
belief that
all of a sudden people will start
accepting this vaccine
dr saud omer the director of yale's
institute for global
health says we need a messaging campaign
that matches the magnitude of a vaccine
program
there's a saying in vaccination it's not
vaccines
that save lives it's vaccination a
vaccine that remains in a vial
is 100 percent safe but zero percent
effective
you know hindsight's always 20 20 it
would have been good if we could have
been having this conversation six months
ago
talking about how a vaccine is developed
and the rigor it goes through
says psychologist stephen taylor you're
saying back in the spring we should have
been talking about this
yeah because we knew this was going to
be a problem operation warp speed
warp speed warp speed warp speed he also
says naming the vaccine program in the
u.s
operation warp speed doesn't help people
need to see that things have been done
properly and corners haven't been cut or
things that haven't been rushed
we're not cutting corner otherwise a
vaccine would already be available now
pharma giant sanofi pasteur has signed
an agreement with the canadian
government
to provide 72 million doses of its
vaccine
made in partnership with glaxosmithkline
if successful
jean-pierre baillette is the general
manager of sanofi pastor canada
i think we don't communicate
sufficiently on all the work that is
done during the clinical trials
how it is tested do people know that
there are 30 000 people in the trial
30 000 can you imagine we're going to
follow up
30 thousand people for six to twelve
months
that will happen once a vaccine reaches
phase three of its clinical trial
sanofi's leading candidate which was
first tested on animals with encouraging
results
has now entered phase two and is being
tried on about 400 people
people are concerned that the speed at
which this vaccine is being developed
could mean that we won't know about
long-term side effects
how do you address those concerns at
sanofi we're using a technology
for the covet vaccine that is already in
use for a flu vaccine
we're going to be able to provide if
successful a vaccine that has already a
long history
safety data so i think this is a very
good start
with polls showing the growing vaccine
concern
nine pharmaceutical companies including
sanofi
signed an historic pledge this past
september vowing to uphold science
and safety but before any vaccine
reaches the public
it will have to be approved by health
canada we want to make sure that the
vaccine is manufactured appropriately
and it's of high quality and the
millionth dose that's
that's produced is exactly the same as
the first dose that's produced
dr supriya sharma is its chief medical
advisor
fundamentally what people want to know
is is this vaccine going to be safe
is there any way for you to guarantee
that what i want to say is that
i will get the vaccine when it's
authorized and if it's when it's my time
i have absolute confidence in the health
canada regulatory review process
and the scientists and the reviewers
that look at these vaccines
to be able to say that health canada
will not authorize a vaccine
if it is if it should not be released
out for for canadians
so where is health canada on that i'm
not hearing a lot about messaging from
health canada right now when it comes to
the vaccine
certainly when the vaccine is any
vaccine is approved we committed to
within 24 hours putting that information
out there
if you were going to give a grade to
governments and pharmaceutical companies
when it comes to their communication
what would it be for governments so far
as vaccines are concerned
i will give them an incomplete grade not
enough
attention has been paid to prepare the
public for what's coming
so your communication campaign doesn't
have to start
with the first product being licensed
you're already too late
we should be bringing the public along
on this journey
heidi larson is the founding director of
the vaccine confidence project
a research group based in london england
she's traveled the world monitoring
concerns over immunization programs
and has seen what happens when they're
not addressed
the most dramatic example that i saw
was in northern nigeria driven by
political distrust
distrust that drove rumors boycotted the
polio vaccine for
11 months but it reinfected with that
virus from nigeria
around 20 countries and cost the global
polio program
500 million dollars to reset the clock
that's because they kept dismissing the
rumors as just rumors
and not listening to well wait a minute
you know maybe there's something that we
need to pay attention to
larson says if we don't respond to the
doubt that's creeping in
the gates are left wide open for other
narratives
and that's exactly what canadians told
us i think just the biggest challenge
that i've been experiencing the sheer
amount of misinformation and misguided
information
really is coming from us from everywhere
well for me i wonder if
the trials are being done on children
and
my kids are of mixed race so are they
going to take to it differently than
their fully caucasian friend
kids will not get the vaccine right away
says dr sharma
with only one clinical trial conducted
by pfizer testing on children 12 and
older
and people from different ethnicities
will be included in phase 3 trials
for my survival rate for my age it's
99.98
i in my situation the risk of a reaction
outweighs
any benefit for me she doesn't know
what if she is 99 because there are a
lot of underlying factors
she may have a lot higher risk than she
thinks she has
and it's not just about fatality
it's about the disabling longer term
symptoms that people should be
considering did you want to take this
opportunity to address the
misinformation is there stuff
circulating vaccines that's
it's it's critical i vaccinate my kids
i vaccinate my parents vaccines are safe
i've heard some people say that that
getting a vaccine is about injecting
myself with a virus
true or false no false you're not
injecting yourself a virus
the common thing we hear i was
vaccinated against influenza and i was
sick
you can't get the flu from your flu shot
what
you inject yourself is dead it's killed
so it cannot generate
a disease so it's a common myth that we
need to
break and we hear that very very often
for larson dispelling these myths and
listening to the concerns
will be the next great test of this
pandemic
covid is a huge opportunity for the
public health
global health community if we get this
one right
that will have a huge value to vaccines
more broadly
if we get this wrong that will not be
forgotten
coming up on the new reality we're in a
valley now it may be a long valley and
in some ways it's a dark and dangerous
valley
but we're going to come out the other
side and i believe we'll come out the
other end of it
better than we are today
the american presidential election in
the middle of a pandemic
is now over and voters in this country
were highly motivated
turnout is set to outpace any election
in the last century
but there was no landslide and the
hard-fought campaign was between men
whose character and beliefs couldn't be
more different
americans were deeply divided before
this election
and they still are my next guest has
some thoughts on that
this is the cbs evening news with dan
rather
for years dan rather was a familiar and
trusted face in millions of american
homes
he took over from walter cronkite at cbs
and was
one of the big three network tv news
anchors
and had a long at times controversial
career at cbs
before starting a new chapter online and
writing essays
defending democratic principles we spoke
earlier this week
you've got a great deal of perspective
on america you've been on the front
lines of huge stories from the
assassination of jfk to the
civil rights movement the vietnam war
what is your assessment
of the state of america right now
well we are deeply divided there's no
question however i think it's important
to
pull back for what we call in television
the wide shot
of the united states of america is not
despite rumors the contrary falling
apart
our institutions have held extremely
well under great pressure
particularly these last three or four
years there are many good things
happening in the country
i hope and i honestly believe will pull
us somewhat together but no one
especially americans should have any
illusions we do have deep problems
and we have to get on those problems
before they get any deeper worse
now many people must rather know you as
a former political reporter and a news
anchor
that was back when people really trusted
the news now
of course there's mistrust in so much in
facts and science and journalism
how damaging is that to america's future
well i think it's already been had some
damage and i think it can be very
damaging going forward
let me say first and foremost those of
us uh in the press
we make mistakes you know the practice
of journalism is not
an exact science it's a kind of crude
art we can't do it perfectly
but we have to do it as best we can
what's happened particularly the last
three and a half to four years
is it been an unrelenting attack on a
broad range of american institutions by
no less than the president himself the
press being one of those institutions
but you know the president he has
attacked individual judges in the courts
he's attacked
his political opponents in the congress
he's attacked the whole field of
journalism not just
individual journalist or particularly
journalists institutions
he said all journalists you know are in
effect quote terrible people
and uh enemies of the people but you
know we know we understand as americans
that the red beating heart of democracy
is a free independent truly independent
seriously independent press when
necessary i do think there's a basic
understanding of that
but it's certainly deteriorated
most especially under tax directly from
the president and it's a serious problem
going forward
you know in the hours after the polls
closed in this election you wrote
victories are rarely easy and the
struggle for healing and hope takes time
and perseverance because the forces of
hate and lies are always easier
to summon that's poignant and it's a
healing message
and you you posted it on facebook
because that's where you found a kind of
renewed life i guess as a journalist and
as a writer
online and yet social media as you know
is such a
uh can be such a sewer and such a place
to spread
lies and hate and amplified so much of
that
how do you navigate the good and the bad
of social media
well not very well in my own case i'm
afraid but you have outlined it very
well
but social media uh is an absolute
cesspool
of misinformation lies conspiracy
theories
but it is also a tremendous tool for
education and information that one of
the things that makes
some of our problems so difficult to
deal with today
is the acceleration of the pace of
change the way
information is distributed primarily the
internet
you know president trump is our first
social media president yes president
obama
dealt in it somewhat but in the same way
that jack kennedy john kennedy
was our first television president
back in the early 1960s that here
president trump has been our first
social media president
he has been a master of manipulating
social media
you may not like him and like his
policies but you have to acknowledge
that he's been
masterful in doing it uh his political
opponents and frankly
some members of press and president
general have not quite caught up with
him
and has given him quite an advantage but
you know going forward we have to we
have to
educate young people of how to navigate
the new media environment which is
overwhelmingly in many ways now
based on the internet itself
is there anyone on the horizon in the
united states who you see
as a potential unifying force
in the country well i'm hesitant to
answer the question because if i name
any one or two people they'll be accused
of buying some
leaving out so many others but i will
say this and and
i hope it's not seen as just sophomoric
or some
uh i'll be journalists just trying to
speak nationalism
but this country is filled with talented
people
it's filled with people with tremendous
leadership
abilities and capacities and that's the
reason i'm an optimist look i know it's
a difficult time
and i'm not some fuzzy-headed well
everything's okay optimist
i'm an optimist who is a realist but by
both experience and nature i'm
optimistic and i'm particularly
optimistic
about the future of our country we're in
a valley now
it may be a long valley and in some ways
it's a dark and dangerous valley
but we're going to come out the other
side and i believe we'll come out the
other end of it
better than we are today coming up
on the new reality here in canada
we've had it pretty good america has
provided a welcome distraction from our
own issues
is that a good thing i'm not sure
it was 52 years ago here in washington
at the press club
that former canadian prime minister
pierre trudeau uttered his famous quote
he said living next to the us is in some
ways like
sleeping with an elephant no matter how
friendly and even-tempered is the beast
he said
one is affected by every twitch and
grunt it was true then
and it's still true today every time the
us has a presidential election canadians
pay close attention
even though we know most americans can't
name our prime minister or our
capital city and think our biggest
export is maple syrup
well stuart reynolds the man known as
brittlestar
thinks maybe that's not such a bad thing
[Music]
here in canada we've had it pretty good
america however has been going through a
rough patch
rising coveted numbers the bulk cause of
which seems to be thanks to groups of
people who
don't want to wear mass think we're all
overreacting
and probably think that birds aren't
real to be fair
there's a good reason those people
believe that and that reason is
those people are not very smart and
let's not forget that non-stop
24 7 reality show america's next old
president
we've been so focused on that
live-action scooby-doo mystery here in
canada that
i had to remind myself not to vote on
their election day
because i'm in canada and not american
america has provided a welcome
distraction from our own issues
is that a good thing i'm not sure
but i can pretty much guarantee that the
scandals that have rocked the nation
here in the great white north
would barely get a tweet if they happen
in america
can you imagine if the wii scandal
happened in the u.s
it'd be a toot in a tuba factory
that's not to say our issues aren't
important they are
vitally but it's like when you'd be out
with your friends for the night
and the next morning as long as you
could with certainty
establish that one of your friends was
drunker
and or stupider than you you were good
you know
like sure i may have cat crawled on top
of the bar but janie threw up on that
guy's shoes
it's good to have someone to distract
from your own problems
but here in canada we should probably
keep working on our own issues
like covet isn't exactly disappearing up
here either
the economy could use some love or
indigenous rights
or racism or
i almost hope that america doesn't get
it all figured out
takes the pressure off us you know
the new reality will be back next
saturday i'm donna friesen
good night
you